[Music]
this world is not yet ready for all that
you will do
your time will come diana
and everything will be different
citizens of the world i'm here to change
your life
anything you want
anything you dream of you can have it
look like you saw a ghost
diana lucky you it's like now one day
has passed
i don't want to be like anyone i want to
be an
apex predator
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
well now it's my turn
get used to it
i remember been one for rules the answer
is always more
the way i fly they will never find us i
forgot to tell you what
radar will they will they shoot at us
[Music]
[Music]
barbara what did you do
you know i'm not so keen on this one i
figure uh you are but
you know what i'm ready to go i think we
can do better
parachute pants yeah um does everybody
parachute now
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
[Music]
his exploits
or legendary
what he has to teach you may very well
mean the difference between life
and death
your reputation precedes you have to
admit i wasn't expecting an invitation
back
they're called orders never
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise is
dog fighting two versus one he's gotta
be kidding
[Music]
smoking the aircraft
and initiate
[Music]
home sequences are
made of this what is this feliz
i'm sorry to be the one to tell you this
but you got yourself killed
at rst we'd rebuild the most important
assets in the us military soldiers like
yourself
you're the first who we've successfully
managed to bring back but
improved enhanced with the technology in
your veins
you have an army inside you that will
not only make you stronger
he will heal you instantly
now tell me do you remember anything
where are you going i gotta finished
business
and kill him
oh that's not good
all right sun down
and initiate sequence
okay who is the next target for
elimination
tell me do you remember anything do i
know you guys i don't think so
i've been manipulating you
what you think is real sometimes i ain't
an initiate sequence
revenge is what makes a man like you
exceptional you know nothing about men
like me
[Music]
that is absolutely fantastic
[Music]
i feel like i just heard this are they
playing with some repeat
i tell people my sister moved out west
you're a science teacher
your husband fee renovates houses
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go
down
that's not my story
before i was an avenger i made mistakes
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
it's called science taskmaster he
controls the red room
they're manipulated fully conscious but
no choices
i should have come back for you how many
others are there
than those
[Applause]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win i've always found it best
you have to look into the past
okay you got a plan or should they just
stay dug and cover my plan was to drive
us away
gloria plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
[Music]
i'm done running
[Music]
here's what's going to happen natasha
don't slouch i'm not slouching you're
going to get the back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god all
right enough
all of you i didn't say anything that's
not fair
[Music]
um
[Music]
mondays am i right joe you said it guy
yeah
don't have a good day have a great day
oh hey bud you ever think that there's
got to be more
more than what stuff we do day after day
being shot at run over
take it hostage everybody's down on the
ground
today's gonna be different hi
god this isn't you you don't do this man
maybe i do
dude this is scary
he's just resting in pieces that man is
dead
he's so sleepy and it's just
[Music]
wow
is this what recreational drugs feel
like
[Music]
guy this world it's a video game
and it's full of bad guys i'm a rule
breaker
i'm a real snaker
we need you to be the good guy
i'm
is that a glock in your pocket no what
it's two blocks oh
[Music]
i'm not gonna be the good guy i'm gonna
be the great guy okay
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
[Music]
virginity
my flock this will not be
a war of heroes
nations will slaughter each other while
we get
rich this is going to be fun
[Music]
[Applause]
you cannot keep me locked away as the
world burns
son the truth is the world is ruled
by corruption and greed we must do
something
certainly
[Music]
we are the first independent
intelligence agency
refined but brutal civilized
but merciless
welcome to the club very clever it's
time
to pour fuel
on the fire of revolution
yes my shepherd
welcome englishman
rasputin your reputation precedes you
[Music]
let's end this as gentlemen after all
manners man
[Music]
why is it that boys are always so messy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and fast cars don't make you batman
[Applause]
get me the [ __ ] out of this car
mike we got more time behind us than in
front please cause i'm gonna be running
down criminals till i'm 100.
not me i'm retiring
what happened to bad boys for life it's
time we be good
man
who the [ __ ] wants to sing that song
mike i'll put you on a new team you're
working with ammo now
cat ammo is a high school musical boy
band with guns
you look great grandpa so you're that
guy there's always one right up till
there's not
that's what i like teamwork
marcus somebody's trying to kill me who
wants to kill you i don't trust a person
that don't want to kill him he'll put my
name up there
thanks a lot we got it marcus we
appreciate it
but family is the only thing that
matters so i'm not letting you go on the
suicide mission alone
one last time one last time
oh [ __ ] get in
let's
there
[Music]
oh this is my wife's car tell me the
front door
she knows she always knows
[Music]
[Music]
last time it was no tennis
one of these bullets is like us
traveling
forwards through time the other one's
going backwards
can you tell which is which
about now
why does it feel so strange yeah
shooting the bullet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
fists for a diplomat
there are people in the future who need
us
[Music]
you got some not gonna like it
time isn't the problem getting out alive
it's a problem
[Music]
you have no idea what you're getting
yourself into if you go through that
door slow motion when i dance
well i'm going so any tips will be
welcome ain't no timer facing scams
what do you think we're saying
the detritus of a coming war
[Music]
[Music]
you want to crash a plane well how big a
plane
that part is a little dramatic
[Music]
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
[Applause]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something none of your ancestors learnt
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one you lose that
one too
arrakis is a death trap
this is an extermination
[Applause]
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
its own leg
to escape what will you do
[Music]
i know you
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
[Music]
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
[Music]
i must not fear
[Music]
fear is the mind killer
hello duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go go
[Music]
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you have a gift you always have
if there's an answer to the disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly
legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
[Music]
strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
even overpowering urge to consume blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
go fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morby got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing
what's up doc
you know what a harlequin is a
harlequin's role
is to serve it's nothing without a
master
no one gives to fraps who we are
beyond that
[Music]
the joker and i broke up
i wanted a fresh start but it turns out
i wasn't the only demon got them looking
for emancipation
this queen she blocks me
who are you guys
[Music]
here's the deal queen you need me
[Music]
he's after all of us now none of us
are walking out of here unless we work
together
[Applause]
with you you've got to be kidding me
[Applause]
i'm the one they should be scared of
[Music]
who's having a good time get ready
[Music]
ladies
[Applause]
lady woman and on occasion [ __ ] [ __ ]
what are you talking about for me
[Music]
listen carefully you are now 5 000 miles
from land
and you're descending seven miles to the
bottom of the ocean
see you all in a month here we go
[Music]
all right we're gonna do this let's do
this
so
we scale from one to ten how bad's my
rig
by ten we drilled to the bottom of the
ocean
and we don't know what came out
gotta get to the station how will you
even get there
we walk we're just gonna walk with
insufficient oxygen across the bottom of
the ocean
you don't know what's out there worst
idea ever
i was deaf turn your lights off
there's something following us
it's pulling me underwater
come on man go
you know what a courtesy type is young
man sounds like this it's light
it's friendly i'm sure that's what your
mom meant to you no it's not
mom
having a kind of a hard time lately i'm
sorry
you accept my apology just ignore it if
you could just do the same we could
press reset i don't have anything to
apologize for
can you go please
ma'am are you okay i'm pretty sure the
guy in that truck's following me
he's road raging why don't you just
chill man go your
way
i don't think you really know what a bad
day is
but you're gonna find out
that man stole my phone
andy i'm sitting here i'm waiting for
you whose phone is i crossed my friend
hey listen to me he's not a friend okay
he's a psycho who came after me today
this is where your first lesson begins
give me my phone
put them back on this goddamn phone no i
can't do that
what do you want i need you to learn
what a bad day really is
and i need you to learn how to say sorry
damn you're gonna learn
through violence and retribution sounds
like you're waking up
why awake you better bring your a-game
cause you're gonna need it
six of our northern cities have fallen
in a coordinated attack
their leader fights alongside a witch
crush these murderers your majesty
every family must contribute one man
to fight you're a war hero you've
already made many great sacrifices
my father cannot fight so i will take
his place
[Applause]
the northern invaders will kill her if i
expose her our own people will kill him
when we take the imperial city
i will take revenge for my father
what is your name soldier hua jin
commander son of karjo
you will now take the oath of the
warrior
loyal great
true
release
[Music]
you will die pretending to be something
you're not
yet here i stand proof that there is a
place for people like us
a girl threatens all plants
[Music]
a warrior
[Applause]
[Music]
i want you to play a game with me ray i
don't want to play a game oh please
no i said play a game with me raymond
right lovely i want you to imagine
a character your boss mickey pearson
you're too smart to be blackmailing us
fletcher
sweet mary jane is my advice your poison
on the other hand is and always has been
the destroyer of the world
you're out of touch and i would like you
to consider an offer
i am not for sale
the plot begins to thicken
now i can't be specific about the heroes
and zeros
but our protagonist is a hungry animal
there is a lot of money hanging in the
balance stream our antagonist
explodes on the scene like a millennial
firework
and has indirectly started a war i think
you need to see this boss what's the one
of my final rocks
how do they find it i'm making inquiries
his name is for hawk we're spelled with
a p asus how's it going for hawk
please all right for hokkaido for hawks
if you smell smoke it's because there's
a fire
so you're gonna have to stamp that out
quickly
these people are going to clean house
and you are part of that house
in the jungle the only way a lion
survives
not by acting like a game
by being the king brilliant
[Music]
oh it's really warming up now isn't it
[Music]
so you killed someone no it was the
gravity that killed him
[Music]
gonna need those phones
[Music]
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
the reason you survived it's because
you're a very
uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time rain
i was 13. i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam
i started panicking people got hurt
roberto my girlfriend a partner
diliana i killed 18 men one
by one
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
[Applause]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
i don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear
and makes you live through it until it
kills you
he's there
we can get out of this together
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign